sam bruce
[Laughter]
sam and dean winchester whoo impressions
gents and apples playing batman in the
long
halloween i didn't realize this until a
few minutes ago a
trailer has come out for this dc
animated movie and i'm so glad it's
being divided into two parts
batman the long halloween
re-read it right before uh the batman
trailer
came out though the week leading into it
because i heard that movie took some
inspiration from it and then christopher
nolan has talked kind of extensively
about how the long halloween
tonally and some plot points were some
of the biggest inspirations for
the dark knight batman year one and the
long halloween are probably my favorite
batman comics
so when i say i'm excited for this i'm
very excited for it
and uh if you haven't read the long
halloween do yourself a favor
it's pretty you've read it right yeah
even i've read the long
videos so what's your excuse when john
made time
so come on it's a great book it's really
good we will avoid spoilers though in
this discussion
as much as possible um in case you
haven't read
some smoking geez now let's get a video
demonetized
i can't really be a lawyer and a
criminal can i
i want to win holiday music do i want to
win like this
i move two minds here so it's a coin
flip
hmm
johnny vade was murdered tonight falcone
crime family has to be taken down
there's only room for one homicidal
maniac in this town
why are you running you could use a
little fun
i thought you didn't have people
you thought wrong
you still haven't figured out who killed
johnny
a killer who only works on holidays
calendar man
lots of crazy out there
solomon grundy my man came out things
are going to be different
we can start a family
the city has fallen alfred then we must
endeavor to lift it up again
who is holiday and who's next
well it's gonna be good
it's gonna be good the thing about the
wb animated movies i haven't seen
although i've seen a good chunk of them
though that's for sure
i feel like the trailers never quite
live up to how good the movies
themselves are
wait a minute didn't jensen ackles voice
jason todd and under the red hood yeah
yeah i'm pretty sure he did sure he's
done an iteration of jason
oh that is even cooler now then they get
you
now he gets to play batman ah that just
came back to me
yeah because under the red hood is it
began like a binge watch phase of mine
for
a lot of the dc animated films what i
got to comment on like
weirdly the first thing is when you see
the cover of the
dvd it's like they're honing in on the
ones we know yeah batman joker and
catwoman when really i'm like
i mean it's more of like batman and
harvey than yeah
like those are like the main featured
characters but you know you gotta hook
the kids in with uh the most exploitable
elements possible
i mean it's kind of a cheesy cover they
got the pumpkin there
yeah yeah i mean it's a halloween
pumpkin yeah yeah and it doesn't really
evoke like not that you have to evoke
the art of the comic book but you know i
mean i feel like it's prolific enough
that there is a certain association with
it and this to me kind of looks like a
video game or an original animated movie
that they shoved onto dvd
or something rather than the adaptation
of one of the most influential batman
stories
and of course because it's a trailer
they're also trying to like hone in more
on the
action set pieces and stuff yeah why not
fight as much as possible
yeah there's some action in there
especially involving the joker like
actually when i think back to the
comic i might be wrong about this but
the the fight sequence that i
specifically think of is the chapters
specifically dedicated to the joker
so it makes sense to kind of showcase
some of that i don't know where they
would
end this like for a part one where in
the storyline would you cut this because
the dc animated movies usually it'll
change a thing
here or there i know with like the
batman hush they really changed like who
hush
was to fit the animated movie but the
long halloween
is is thick enough but i mean just look
at this it's pretty thick for
a graphic novel you know that's 13
issues worth boy
yeah it's i'm i'm like what is the exact
halfway point of this book you know yeah
yeah so chapter 7 would be april fool's
day if you guys don't know
the comic at all basically there's a
murder that occurs on a halloween night
and then it spans a year-long
investigation
and you hop around to the holidays
basically
you know thanksgiving christmas all
trying to hunt down the holiday killer
so maybe chapter seven would be the um
part one end point perhaps i mean six
and a half or seven mathematically
speaking i could see this probably
ending after the joker's storyline and
then part two could probably be really
long
that's yeah i feel like you could easily
crescendo with
that and then yeah have the substantial
you know
wrap-up portion be the r-rated more
in-depth movie
yeah yeah because a lot of the stuff
that i really love doesn't seem to be
that featured here in the trailer
you know which is in in the last half of
the book specifically i love the whole
thing pretty much from beginning to end
but yeah this
seems a little bit more focused on like
oh we're going to explore more of the
joker
side of things yeah absolutely and then
yeah then
maybe exploring the hero side of harvey
dent in part one
and then watching the downfall and
deterioration of harvey down to the
two-face
in part two yes and i'm excited we're
finally gonna see some calendar man
and solomon grundy is there i mean
calendar man especially
he's one of the batman villains who
needs to do and i didn't see any
riddler in here he's more featured in
part two a lot of the characters in her
poison i'd be supposed to be in here you
know there's a whole bunch of characters
and what would be great about this
experience is it's very apparent
the batman with robert pattinson is
drawing from way more inspiration than
even just batman comics alone martin
from chinatown seven look like a very
big inspiration for it
but i think what will be neat is if you
watch this you'll easily see stuff of oh
yeah the dark knight
definitely pulled from this and i think
if you just go and watch the batman
trailer you'll be like oh yeah the
batman's
definitely pulling from this so i think
that's going to be part of the
fun of it all a good study guide for
everybody going into bed
who doesn't want to re-eat all that well
i mean they have the whole falcone
family element in here which is a big
part of batman begins in the dark knight
yeah absolutely i'm kind of surprised
that this is a pg actually you know what
no i think about it now they can get
away with being pg-13
i think one thing these dc animated
movies tend to do where they take a
little bit more liberty
as demonstrated in this trailer they
enhance the action sequences a lot more
make them more violent more bloody a lot
more choreography yeah yeah
choreographed but i mean this looks
really cool from an animation
perspective
too because i like the variants it's
like i think you know dc does a really
good job with their animated movies but
there's often you know kind of a uniform
style and you know the long halloween as
a book has a distinctive
style with these distinctive sort of
watercolory splashes
and like the texture they've imbued a
lot of this stuff with especially on
these like gotham city wide
shots looks really beautiful but also
really tangible in a way i'm not as used
to seeing here so that got me really
excited and now yeah i just want to see
like a scene breathe because if there's
one thing i i didn't get a
full sense of was just like who jensen
echols batman really would be it's like
all the lines he gets are really short
yeah so i feel like i i just need to now
hear what his
bruce and batman are truly like his
voice has the perfect timbre for it you
know well it's funny about the marketing
for these movies is they that the
marketing moves at such a whiplash pace
yeah yet the movies feel so much more
mature
like they feel like oh a kid's movie
yeah these are bass
like trailers for a kid's video movie
yeah then you watch him and you're like
this is
kind of just pretty mature i do like the
animation
overall i'm not a hundred percent in
love with it i get you got to adapt it
and i get you got to make it an
enjoyable viewing experience but it
looks like a dc animated movie
like a little anime sprinkled into some
of the face structures and stuff
yeah yeah yeah it's it's more it's what
i'm kind of used to
seeing i kind of miss that jeff lowe tim
sayle
look which was a lot more phil noir
grimy you know it felt like really
distinct
whereas here this seems like they've
taken some of that but
really polished it up and sort of
smashed it into the general look of the
dc animated universe
yeah to create uniformity or something
like that yeah
i mean if you've seen like our coverage
for other dc animated movies before i'm
less
critical about certain elements but it's
like the long halloween is one i really
love like batman and but it's like
that's the thing though i love batman
year one the graphic novel and i loved
the dc animated movie as well
i usually have like a lot of faith i'll
pull it off yeah
i mean it's the kind of thing it's like
it's a big enough and important enough
story that it could marry
completely immersing in that art style
but at the same time i can imagine
if you know once this has a chance to
breathe maybe they do make for an
actually pretty decent meld or something
right you know
who's playing joker oh [ __ ]
it's troy baker joel from the last of
us and and batman arkham knight awesome
pedigree there you go justice for joe oh
hell yeah
dude oh hell yeah
all right guys well what did you think
about
this trailer are you excited for it to
be brought to life leave your thoughts
down below you can subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button last but not least
eric horstmann i really want you to make
your own batman movie i think you would
be the greatest bruce away in this world
has ever seen don't don't don't
try to get too into character i want
this to be your personality i want him
to have a drink in hand who's your
alfred man because i bet your alfred
would be a fascinating guy
what kind of crime would eric wayne have
to solve
it would probably be something pretty
ridiculous right
i'm trying to brainstorm and it's not
going to be anywhere near as good as
just what would happen
in your actual life if you turn on a
camera
got a bat cowl maybe don't put on the
rest of the costume man i mean it's up
to you his bat suit
would probably just be assless chaps and
then the bat
cowl and the cape and maybe the
gauntlets and that's it
you know like like kind of like remember
that time that you cooked hot dogs and
vicious dogs in your underwear
and the batman cape i've been totally
listening
definitely listening to this super yes
and that was
that was much good uh eric we love you
please make this home movie for me
that's my request if you never
ever contribute anything to our
operation again just just give me
an eric bruce wayne home movie that's
all i want that's it
that's that's my long halloween present
right who do we shout out uh andrew
[Music]
hayes